[Musique]
développer cette citation dieu m'a donné
la foi puis je ne sais quoi c'est la
lumière qui guide mes pas ah bah oui
bon ce soir c'est ce à quoi je donne à
quoi bon dieu apollon là on a la lumière
ça c'est obligé mais parfois la lumière
ne marche pas mais c'est pas la lumière
du jour c'est la lumière d'un apport
pour vous soyez que ça voudrait à une
taille vous êtes encore avec 2 est
toujours avec nous au brier dans votre
maison partout hein mais mon grenier
partout et dans la cades qui es tu toi
qui me tutoie si tu me tues toi je te
tutoie
airbus est sur l'affiché pas il m'a dit
qu'ils ont des soucis de finition
et ça c'est pas bien
c'est pas comme on peut ce n'est pas
parce que tu n'as jamais vu le lion
chasse etc il est végétarien
filou besoin de rien envie de toi comme
jamais envie de personnes c'est un truc
2 c'est un peu chaud ça non ça peut
l'être ça dépend comme on le comprend on
comprend si on le prend pas au point de
vue physique ou au point de vue
spirituel ah oui un ya aussi le point de
vue spirituel alors la dame a dit qu tu
peux penser soit au cul soit la tête
quoi
besoin de toi envie de personnes c'était
un couple ringard dans les années quatre
75 81 85 comment il s'appelait quoi
qu'est ce tu dit peter et sloane itx
voilà à quelles sont jolies les filles
de mon pays là il ay lay lay lay lay ah
oui c'est court ces citations de ricoh
macias 2 noriko macias et qu'elles sont
jolies les filles de mon pays il faut
développer
aimez vous développez donc faut parler
de la perte de l'algérie du regret du
pays perdu
oui de tous sont passés de toute la
nostalgie que çà et
là
l'ice et
laï laï laï laï pour entraîner tout le
monde dans son délire ah ouais il se
drogue alors
comprendre un mot vous lui souffler
ouais je soutiens un micro et sécher la
wii c'est pas normal la philo s'en fout
un peu c'est ça sert pas à grand chose
je suis pas d'accord
il doit faire un pas de plus et c'est
tout voilà bien fait pour ta gueule a
cure dites lui bien fait pour ta gueule
est fait pour vous il faut pas tricher
j'aime pas les tricheurs voilà t'es un
[ __ ]
williams a foiré une heure durant enore
dure une couille molle ah non non j'aime
pas non non non c'est trop c'est trop
non un peu mais bon voilà nous on écoute
nous on s'en va avec la dame on va faire
l'amour et puis tu te démerdes pas
certainement pas su marier emmerdes
[Musique]